it's rich people dan balzerian dude yeah
some big some big news on you know the
king the king alpha male the king alpha
male
danny b dan bilzerian you know and
a really an icon in all of our eyes
um well apparently you might be
you know it might be a fraud yeah who
would have thought
but maybe you know i don't know if this
is true or not but i mean it's
definitely true that
the guy that they chose i guess of the
guy i read the article the guy that they
chose
as to be like the president of ignite
he left the company or he got fired i
think he got fired because
he blew the whistle yeah he basically
blew the whistle on like how much the
company was spending on dan's lifestyle
because like the house is a is 200 grand
a month
and the company pays for it you know and
they've raised like 50 million bucks or
something like that
and the company pays for all the trips
all the models everything and so he was
concerned with this and they fired him
and now he's trying to he's suing them
for wrongful termination
and all of this is part of the lawsuit
that all of this like egregious spending
so that danny b can be the idol of every
13 year old
bro but when when it says someone else
pays his credit card bills
what i'm wondering is is the money for
ignite being like pumped in like what
you're saying is it coming from
moneyland from somewhere else
from his [ __ ] dad you know what i'm
saying
no but he has investors
oh they're public in investors i'm
pretty sure
oh that's the money
wait let me just double check oh man
would be
so funny if this whole [ __ ] came
crashing down
oh my goodness the final post by dan
bilzerian could you imagine
yeah could you [ __ ] imagine
the scam comes to an end ignite is part
of vulcan enterprises us
okay which i think is a public company
i think i don't know the way that this
works dude but i know
that something's fishy bro
ignite lost 50 million last year
and the rent on his place is 2.4 million
dollars a year a year
yep get the [ __ ] out of here
i mean like it's this is poetry isn't it
this something like this oh yeah i mean
i can't wait till the whole thing
collapses and then they get the clip of
him on the
on the rogan podcast being like well i
got all my money from poker
[Music]
i can't wait and not that i you know not
that i
want him to fail because i don't care
that much but
it's annoying how he puts it in your
face that he's like
i'm richer than you i'm this than you
i'm that than you and it's
if it's like no i mean the whole time he
uses a [ __ ] skeez ball [ __ ] you
yeah i guess that's the problem with it
is that he makes it part of his brain
and his message that
he's living the life that you should be
living and
it's your fault that you're not doing
this stuff yeah i'm just i'm just having
sex and
living free and it's just you know
because you decide to bow to the
corporate overlords
yeah you aren't doing the same thing too
and it's like well
it's also costs a [ __ ] ton of money
somebody's got to pay for it eventually
yeah and if you don't do it legitly
that's going to catch up to you
i don't appreciate some someone calling
me a [ __ ] [ __ ] and
all this and that when it's like bro
your whole the whole thing is rented
you don't even own it yeah [ __ ] you man
you're regular like the rest of us
yeah i think that's the biggest thing
yep
even even if he came out of it where
it's like he doesn't
live in a in a 10 trillion dollar house
now he just lives in a regular million
dollar house i go
that's what you always were yeah you
know you [ __ ] liar
it does like there is a little bit of
you know i don't know
whatever that's saying whatever that
word is like shattered
or whatever where you see something
where everyone is like how this just
looks fake
i mean how yeah how it can't be real it
can't be real and then finally someone
comes out and says
i know i'm on the inside and it's not
real and yeah
thank god i'm not crazy yeah i think
yeah that's definitely the
the most of it that's i think that's the
majority of people
is they want to feel like they're not
crazy for looking at that
and isn't it isn't that wild at least i
in my experience
when i would bring up like no this is
[ __ ] [ __ ]
people would [ __ ] tell me man you
just you just you're just jealous or
you're hating or
you wish that was you like in regards to
him
yeah and like doubting what the [ __ ] he
had i was like
there's no [ __ ] way yeah it's not
real like hey man if he says you got it
from this like this
is what it is it's like no yeah he it's
all from poker
dude poker monday like this doesn't
exist no that's that's that was my
biggest thing
is you look at the the best the biggest
pros in the world
these dudes live in vegas they don't
pay like you know what i mean like yeah
they live a certain way so that that
money is protected
and i'd like i know a couple dudes that
like got up in poker pretty decent
and that money is not there all the time
so i'm like you're on [ __ ] yachts off
poker
[ __ ] you yeah um
i'm just on his instagram now to look at
more ridiculous [ __ ]
this dude has a tank with the ignite
brand oh it's not a tank it's a
army truck still yeah still
that's what that's what it was that's
part of the lawsuit is that he said that
he would just slap the ignite logo on
everything
and it would become a marketing expense
so he's just expensing all this [ __ ]
bro on this jet no way
yeah yeah it's pretty wild it's also you
know what's weird is that like
it's just always him and 15 girls
yep they're all on the payroll yep so
where where
like how just i don't know i i
even if even if you're you know cause
i'm i'm assuming he he went on some
what was it oh oh i i someone someone
sent me
his he was doing a q a on his instagram
story hell yeah
and someone sent me one of his answers
and it was like i don't know it was
stupid
and so i like backtracked through the
other questions and one of them was how
many times a day do you have sex
and he said two or three a day
so like you know he's having sex with
these women
and it's like but they're also on the
payroll
yeah so is that weird for you
yeah these girls are paid to spend time
with you does it feel
real like there's no way
there's no i mean i mean it probably
doesn't
i mean this picture right here is funny
to me because this
[ __ ] guy fieri outfit he has on
yeah like i don't know something about
this to me just screams a little kid
i don't know why like just like the
little camo shorts and the nikes
yeah and the plain white just like i
yeah i have sex with like 15 girls and i
go in the big airplane and i go
to the beach and it's like all right
cool but yeah now i agree with you that
i think you have to be pretty empty
inside to like even want to keep this up
you know
but yeah why why is hugh hefner like a
legend
because it was the same [ __ ] wasn't it
you had girls living with them
but they were all models they're all
getting paid that all wanted to be in
playboy
i mean yeah but i guess with hugh maybe
it was like um
maybe it's because like it started with
like a publication and
and maybe there's like a degree of
actual
you know was you haven't was this dad
rich
i have no idea cause yeah i thought he
was self-made
he founded playboy which you could argue
is um maybe it's a bit perverse
and it's like thinly veiled perversion
or you know can you argue that it's like
art or something or he's
breaking the status quo where he's like
man all these [ __ ] magazines are
so [ __ ] safe [ __ ] that we're just
gonna we're gonna put people
butt ass naked uh and and you know
we're gonna like you know we're gonna
appeal to
what real life is like i don't know yeah
but i mean danny b
created ignite that's the best cbd
company that there is
that's another thing is that they
started as cannabis like weed
and stuff and then they i guess they
pivoted to cvd yeah tbd
which which i guess is you know it's
almost the same thing but not really
because
they started as like a real weed company
and now it's like
you know placebo essentially
it's just scammy like the whole thing
dude i'm sorry these pictures he's got
on here are just
hysterical to me it's just what is this
these are pictures that are just like on
accident yeah
him eating a pizza on his stomach you
look like a five-year-old man i'm sorry
i earned this body and i built this
temple with nothing more than
some elbow grease and a little can-do
attitude
and yes a large inheritance from my
father earl
okay okay so he acknowledges it there
all right
okay at least he's honest maybe he does
i mean i
who knows who knows man maybe he's maybe
he does have a [ __ ] ton of money from
his dad
he's just still using or still expensing
this stuff
to not pay taxes yeah or to not
to to not pay as many taxes on it
yeah maybe he's just [ __ ] minted for
life so none of this [ __ ] matters
yeah who knows man who knows
you